so corinna lage in deutschland jetzt der
gesundheitsminister und der chef des
robert koch-instituts mühe zu
organisieren die von interesse sind für
unsere mitglieder und das ist
entspannt sie haben das wort liebe frau
welti meine damen und herren in
absprache mit der bundespressekonferenz
werden wir in der nächsten zeit wieder
wöchentlich an dieser stelle zur krone
lageberichten für diese möglichkeit
möchte ich mich ausdrücklich bedanken
der regelmäßige krone -bericht wieder
wöchentlich ist aus unserer sicht in
dieser lage auch erforderlich das
erlaubt uns nicht nur ihre fragen zu
beantworten sondern schafft auch das
öffentliche bewusstsein dafür wie die er
wie ernst die situation ist und die
situation ist ernst und ich empfehle uns
allen sie auch ernst zu nehmen die
infektionszahlen steigen sehr stark wir
liegen inzwischen bei einer sieben tage
incidents von über 260 und die
ansteckungsrate der er wert ist schon
viel zu lange
seit ende september deutlich über 1 das
heißt wenn nichts passiert werden sich
die instanzen weiter alle zwei wochen
verdoppeln ich habe im juli mal gesagt
wir müssen im oktober mit instanzen von
800 und mehr rechnen wenn auch etwas
später ist dass das was wir jetzt auch
in einigen regionen sehen
was so hohe infektionszahlen bei
gleichzeitig noch zu geringer impfquote
bedeuten sehen wir bereits jetzt auf den
intensivstationen in einigen regionen in
deutschland insbesondere in sachsen
thüringen und bayern es gibt dort
kliniken die sind heute schon über dem
limit in diesen regionen
besteht aktuell das risiko wenn sie ein
notfall sind schlaganfall herzinfarkt
dass dort nicht immer sofort vor ort die
kapazitäten zur verfügung stehen die sie
sonst gewohnt werden das ist bitter und
das ist die situation die wir immer
vermeiden wollten und weiter vermeiden
wollen wir müssen jetzt alles tun alles
notwendige tun um diese dynamik zu
brechen sonst wird es für das unser land
ein bitterer dezember
die gesundheitsminister von bund und
länder haben vor einer woche in lindau
oder zu drei wichtige punkte beschlossen
zum einen auffrischimpfungen für alle
nach sechs monate nach der zweiten
impfung schärfere auflagen und
kontrollen beim zugang zur veranstaltung
und verpflichtende test konzepte für
pflegeheime beim impfen sehen wir und
das ist gut wieder mehr tempo wir haben
auch deutlich anziehende bestellungen
seitens der länder und der arztpraxen
wären allein in dieser woche wieder über
4,3 millionen impfdosen an die
impfzentren an die länder und an den
großhandel für die arztpraxen
ausgeliefert das ist eine vervierfachung
im vergleich zu dem was wir in den
letzten wochen gesehen haben
mittlerweile haben über zehn prozent der
über 60 jährigen in deutschland eine auf
geschimpfe erhalten hier in berlin
geringst sogar schon über 20 prozent
alle länder haben sich mittlerweile
entschieden die älteren schriftlich über
die auffrischimpfung zu informieren und
sie ihnen zu empfehlen die länder und
die behörden vor ort fahren auch die
öffentlichen angebote wieder hoch wir
haben stand heute wieder über 170
impfzentren und stellen im land und über
600 mobile im teams der öffentlichen des
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienstes die
impfungen anbieten und ich werde per
verordnung sicherstellen dass die
impfzentren der länder bis mindestens
ende april weiterhin zur hälfte vom bund
finanziert werden
wir bieten zudem den ärztinnen und
ärzten in den arztpraxen anreize um
ihren praxisalltag auf das impfen
auszurichten wir werden die vergütung
für die impfung erhöhen von 20 auf 28
euro um 40 prozent und es wird ein
wochenend zuschlag geben von nochmal
acht euro für jede impfung so dass dann
eine impfung am wochenende 80 prozent
besser vergütet wird als heute
diese verordnung werde ich am montag
unterzeichnen das geht dann ab dienstag
impfen macht den entscheidenden
unterschied das gilt auch weiterhin aber
das impfen braucht eben auch zeit
es ist eine volle wirkung jeweils
entfalten kann deswegen müssen wir in
dieser lage rasch wieder deutlich mehr
testen dazu ist ja vereinbart führen wir
die kostenlosen bürger tests wieder ein
und sichern damit auch den kurzfristigen
wiederaufbau einer flächendeckenden test
infrastruktur finanziell ab die test
verordnung die das möglich macht die die
bürger tests wieder einführte
unterzeichne ich heute sie gilt ab
morgen und ich gehe davon aus dass dann
ab anfang der woche nach und nach auch
wieder das angebot vor ort ausgebaut
wird und mehr verfügbar ist ich
appelliere an alle bürgerinnen und
bürgern die angebotenen im pfund
testmöglichkeiten auch zu nutzen
allerdings und das sage ich mit der
erfahrung aus drei corona wellen das ist
alles richtig und wichtig aber
das reicht so alles nicht jedenfalls
nicht mehr es braucht dringend
zusätzlich eine testpflicht für personal
und
besucher im pflegeheim das ist im
übrigen auch wichtiger als eine
verpflichtende impfung in diesem bereich
weil auch geimpfte und genießen besucher
und beschäftigte in den
pflegeeinrichtungen aus unserer sicht
regelmäßig getestet werden müssen
idealerweise täglich um den eintrag in
die pflegeeinrichtung zu vermeiden es
braucht 3g am arbeitsplatz ist es gut
dass gewerkschaften und arbeitgeber das
nun mittragen und eine gesetzliche
regelung kommen soll
und dann werden wir uns auch über die
auflagen für veranstaltungen unterhalten
müssen 3g war eine gute idee aber es
geht zu oft theorie 3g war zu oft 0 g
weil es nicht wirklich kontrolliert
worden ist und damit auch keinen
wirklichen effekt erzielen konnte das
können wir uns nicht mehr erlauben nicht
in dieser lage
mehr noch 3g alleine wird nicht mehr
reichen wenn wir die aktuelle dynamik
der pandemie wirklich brechen wollen
müssen wir entschlossener handeln
und dazu gehört eben auch das testen bei
dieser hohen inzidenz wo auch die
kämpfen und genesenen teil der
infektions entwicklung in deutschland
sind das geht dann eben auch durch
testen bei geimpften und genesenden
deshalb wäre es aus meiner sicht aus
unserer sicht konsequent wenn wir
öffentliche veranstaltungen erstens nur
für geimpfte und genesene ermöglichen
und zweitens nur dann wenn diese
zusätzlich einen aktuellen test
verweisen zweig plus das ist wieder ein
schwerer schritt
ist mir sehr bewusst aber ich bin davon
überzeugt das ist ein schritt den wir
gehen müssen und wir können ihn nur
gemeinsam gehen die instrumente für das
was ansteht haben wir wir müssen sie
aber eben auch anwenden und
kontrollieren und es braucht ein
gemeinsames signal dass wir uns gegen
diese vierte welle stemmen auch deshalb
brauchen wir die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz das treffen
von bund und ländern aus meiner sicht
hätten wir schon vor drei wochen
gebraucht die vielstimmigkeit der
vorschläge der letzten wochen haben nur
für verwirrung gesorgt und sie haben
dazu geführt dass zu viele die krone
auflagen nicht mehr ernst nehmen so
schwer das ist in dieser zeit des
übergangs zwischen alter und neuer
regierung wir müssen wieder eine
gemeinsame sprache finden und zu einem
gemeinsamen handeln kommen um leid zu
verhindern um eine überlastung unseres
gesundheitswesens zu verhindern und um
die bevölkerung mitzunehmen
auf diesem schweren weg jetzt insa
vierten welle der pandemie die so in
dieser dimension viele so mein eindruck
nicht mehr erwartet haben wir sehen im
übrigen das hinzufügen darf aber gestern
mein dänischen kollegen getroffen
beim niederländischen kollegen gerade
austausch gehabt auch viele andere
länder in europa die schon weiter waren
auch bei lockerung sehen jetzt in dieser
vierten welle das eben weitere maßnahmen
wieder nötig sind und weitere maßnahmen
gemeinsam durch diese vierte welle das
geht nur entschlossen und gemeinsam zu
tag meine damen und herren man darin
kann es ist fünf nach zwölf
das hier ist die aktuelle karte der
sieben tages insolvenzen aus deutschland
sie sehen dass fast alle landkreise
tiefrot sind im süden und im osten sehen
sie auch diese pinkfarbenen landkreise
das sind etliche landkreise in denen die
sieben tage incidents über 500 liegt
und vielen liegt über 800 der 904 sogar
über 1000 in diesen bundesländern kommen
krankenhäuser und intensivstationen
jetzt schon an ihre kapazitätsgrenzen
und ist nicht absehbar dass sich die
lage doch entspannen wird andere
bundesländer sind im moment noch nicht
an diesem punkt wir müssen aber davon
ausgehen dass sich die situation überall
in deutschland weiter verschärfen wird
und das ohne zusätzliche maßnahmen auch
nicht mehr aufzuhalten ist die inzidenz
steigen teilweise sprunghaft an vor
allem bei den fünf bis 19 jährigen aber
auch in allen anderen altersgruppen auf
den intensivstationen liegen bereits
mehr als 2800
komapatienten die behandlungskapazitäten
schwinden
derzeit gibt es tatsächlich so wenig
betreibt bahre betten wie noch nie in
dieser pandemie mehr als die hälfte der
intensivstation melden dem intensiv
register akute personalengpässe so viel
wie zuletzt auf dem bisherigen höhepunkt
im januar diesen jahres die vierte welle
trifft uns jetzt mit voller wucht und je
schneller und je höher sie sich auftun
desto schwieriger wird es sie auch unter
kontrolle zu bringen und desto
verheerender sind natürlich die folgen
ich möchte dass anhand der aktuellen
infektionszahlen der oz million
aktuellen hospitalisierung skate und dem
fall verstorbenen anteil einmal
verdeutlichen gestern wurden erstmals
über 50.000 fälle an einem einzigen tag
über mittel zu viel wie noch nie von
diesen 50.000 fällen an einem tag werden
im laufe der zeit etwa 3000 im
krankenhaus behandelt werden
von diesen 50.000 fällen müssen
schätzungsweise
mindestens
350 auf die intensivstation und nach
einiger zeit werden von diesen 50.000
menschen mindestens 200 versterben
natürlich können die zahlen die ich hier
genannt habe auch schwanken das hängt
von vielen faktoren haben je mehr ältere
personen betroffen sind desto höher sind
die sterbefall zahlen zum beispiel es
geht mir darum ihnen diese größenordnung
klar zu machen
das ist die bilanz von einem tag mit
50.000 fällen momentan und es ist wie
gesagt absehbar dass die fallzahlen
weiter ansteigen vor uns liegen also
schwere wochen und monate wir müssen
jetzt ansteckungen verhindern
kurzfristig durch die uns allen
bekannten bewährten infektionsschutz
maßnahmen und mittelfristig durch mehr
impfungen wenn sie noch nicht geimpft
sind lassen sie dich bitte impfen wenn
eine auffrischungsimpfung für sie
empfohlen ist lassen sie sich bitte ihre
auffrischungsimpfung holen um die
situation so rasch wie möglich zu
entschärfen müssen alle zusätzlich ihr
verhalten ändern reduzieren sie ihre
kontakte vermeiden sie vor allen
situationen den mehrere menschen in
räumt zusammenkommen bitte hallt sich
immer überall andrea h und l regel auch
bei 2g und 3g veranstaltungen haben sie
also auch bei 2g eine maske wenn sie
symptome einer akuten atemwegsinfektion
haben bleiben sie bitte unbedingt zu
hause und lassen sich kapp ecr testen
darüber hinaus empfiehlt das robert
koch-institut je nach situation auch
weitere zusätzliche maßnahmen in unserem
kontroll kobik dokument stellen wir
schon lange einen stufenplan zur
verfügung wie hilft die lage in den
bundesländern einzuordnen und wir
empfehlen für jede stufe angepasste
maßnahmen
und zwar für verschiedene settings eine
bundes einige bundesländer haben bereits
die höchste stufe dieses planes die
stufe 2 erreicht in dieser stufe zwei
reicht 2d alleine nicht mehr aus um das
infektionsgeschehen einzudämmen für
stufe 2 1 führt das robert koch institut
deshalb weiter kontakt reduktion dass
man zb bei großveranstaltungen
veranstaltungen die personenzahl
reduziert oder ein verbot erwägt das man
aber in erwägung ziehen sollte auch bars
oder clubs zu schließen für stufe 2
empfiehlt das rki auch dass sich alle
auch geimpfte und genesene testen bevor
sich auch privat mit risikogruppen
treffen alle diese empfehlungen haben
wir seit september in der aktuellen
kontroll kurve strategie auf unserer
startseite abrufbar sie müssen jetzt
umgesetzt werden wir befinden uns in
einer sehr ernsten lage wir haben es
jetzt in der hand jede unnötige
infektion zu vermeiden bitte lassen sie
uns doch einfach gemeinsam jetzt handeln
jede person in deutschland ab zwölf
jahren kann sich schützen wir haben
sichere und wirksame impfungen vergessen
wir nicht dass wir auch immer noch eine
gruppe von menschen haben die sich noch
nicht impfen lassen können alle kinder
unter zwölf jahren sind das nämlich aber
auch die müssen wir doch schützen und
die schützen wir mit wenn wir uns impfen
lassen wir könnten das virus übertragen
ohne es zu wissen oder uns mit dem virus
anstecken ohne es zu ahnen
diese kette müssen wir durchbrechen wir
können das tun indem wir unser verhalten
anpassen und verantwortungsbewusst
handeln
vorbeugen ist besser als heilen